- We are asked what is the distance
between the following points.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
There's multiple ways to think about it.
The way I think about it
is really to try to draw
a right triangle where these points,
where the line that connects
these points is the hypotenuse
and then we can just use
the Pythagorean Theorem.
Let me show you what I am talking about.
Let me draw a right triangle, here.
That is the height of my right triangle
and this is the width
of my right triangle.
Then the hypotenuse will
connect these two points.
I could use my little
ruler tool here to connect
that point and that
point right over there.
I'll color it in orange.
There you have it.
I have a right triangle
where the line that connects
those two points is the
hypotenuse of that right triangle.
Why is that useful?
From this, can you pause
the video and figure out
the length of that orange
line, which is the distance
between those two points?
What is the length of this red line?
You could see it on this grid, here.
This is equal to two.
It's exactly two spaces, and
you could even think about it
in terms of coordinates.
The coordinate of this point up here
is negative five comma eight.
Negative five comma eight.
The coordinate here is
X is four, Y is six.
Four comma six, and so
the coordinate over here
is going to have the same
Y coordinate as this point.
This is going to be comma six.
It's going to have the same
X coordinate as this point.
This is going to be
negative five comma six.
Notice, you're only
changing in the Y direction
and you're changing by two.
What's the length of this line?
You could count it out, one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
It's nine, or you could even say hey look,
we're only changing in the X value.
We're going from negative five,
X equals negative five, to X equals four.
We're going to increase by nine.
All of that just sets us up so that
we can use the Pythagorean Theorem.
If we call this C, we know
that A squared plus B squared
is equal to C squared, or we
could say that two squared ...
Let me do it over here.
Use that same red color.
Two squared plus nine
squared, plus nine squared,
is going to be equal to
our hypotenuse square,
which I'm just calling C, is
going to be equal to C squared,
which is really the distance.
That's what we're trying to figure out.
Two squared, that is four,
plus nine squared is 81.
That's going to be equal to C squared.
We get C squared is equal to 85.
C squared is equal to 85 or C
is equal to the principal root of 85.
Can I simplify that a little bit?
Let's see.
How many times does five go into 85?
It goes, let's see, it goes 17 times.
Neither of those are perfect squares.
Yeah, that's 50 plus 35.
Yeah, I think that's about
as simple as I can write it.
If you wanted to express it as a decimal,
you could approximate it by
putting this into a calculator
and however precise you want
your approximation to be.
That over here, that's
the length of this line,
our hypotenuse and our right triangle,
but more importantly for
the question they're asking,
the distance between those points.